now you know I spent a lot of time
around game developers during the final
hours of development on their games and
sometimes you just can't do anything but
think about finishing your game and you
can't travel anywhere you're focused in
the studio but now it's time to
introduce a guest to his only weeks away
from finishing his next title but that
didn't stop him from flying halfway
around the world to be here at Gamescom
with us tonight I'm so honored that he's
here
you may know who I'm talking about but
take a look at this
[Applause]
travel to tonight's awards ceremony to
accept any awards gift please enjoy
one and only a day of the Jima
[Applause]
such an honor to work with you you're
such a genius he is one of the most
principled loyal and ethical man I have
ever met I have gained was out of this
world I did rebel you all from my heart
I do anything
[Music]
Gamescom stranded on your feet
he's here the ones only al-khatib ah
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. kijima it is such an honor to have
you with us
I know how hard you've been working to
finish up no game is cool
I know gone everybody okay I returned
after five years to visit games come
again it's great to have you back and
everyone's great look at the selfies
happening I know this is surrounding
this naima sweet it's a nice easy key
there hunter game beaucoup now in this
kiddo wall / - honey are you I know they
got the keymaster
des trending is in the final really
crunch time of development stage and I
shouldn't actually be here but I really
wanted to meet you all
so I came to Germany which is so amazing
so mr. kijima
we know that your as you said just about
finishing up the game and everyone's
very curious the whole world is curious
what you can tell us about this game and
what you want to share tonight with all
of us so what can you tell us about what
you want to introduce a game with a
motocross I know
gusano yes trending is a totally new
game it's an open world game and it's a
very very new and I hope that everyone
will like it then of course Naomi Conde
her tomorrow Tara Socastee Hawaii had a
character ahsoka is or two top visited
over us
so since it was quite popular to show a
new character at Comic Con
today I would like to introduce more new
characters today hey let's look at the
first one okay let's take a look at the
first character for mr. kijima
[Music]
[Applause]
even though she can't drink it my body
keeps making it going through the
motions really helps with the soreness
though what is she she's my daughter and
I'm her mama it's okay
she's only connected to me it's not like
the other B teeth can see it right
you're hooked other
now you know why I can't leave
[Applause]
[Music]
so there are a lot of characters appear
in death trending and each unique
character has like a sub story from
apart from the main story
Monica no Kijang como anima is an
enumerative so no one'll catch onto his
modus annotation crusted it to City
maturities so Mama's setting is that her
baby was born unfortunately on the other
side and not in her world so but however
they are still connected by the
umbilical cord so that's why she can't
that's how they kind of exist no
syndicate Santo she no sekai de it's not
this so Coco can I call a solar
collectors so she's a she has a sad
background where she can't move because
her baby is actually on the other side
and she's on the the real world and
they're still connected that's why she
can't move from that location
hi years old I have another one to see
oh okay let's check it out we got a lot
of stuff for you
[Applause]
deadman you there little help okay
remove the party connected to that
incubator
it's in good he did very excessive
stresses easily addresses who return him
to his mother's womb mother located in
the capital not City I see you bring
that of course
he means still mother correct hey still
mother who facilitates the connections
between the world of the dead and the
baby and you in turn connect yourself to
a baby granting you the ability to sense
Metis these thoughts were designed to
simulate the conditions inside a steel
mother's womb babies need to believe is
there anyone at all times to function
properly however he can only maintain
this deception for so long which is why
we must periodically update the
environmental data by synchronizing it
with a steel mother via the chiral
network
there the update is in progress right
now the Odysseys furnaces with the steel
mother in capital not City and
reconfiguring it citizens based on the
latest data returning your BB to the
womb in this manner temporarily reduces
stress levels that being where it
technically belongs of course kid looks
at me is just a thousand doses how the
top Xenia shouldn't city much lower for
now on you should remember that babies
are just equipment try not to get
attached each one has been physically
removed from its deal mother's womb a
process that renders then an
unpredictable prone to failure no BP on
record has remained in service for over
a year it may need to be retired before
this expedition is over
you see there's no way to keep my baby
alive you must understand there is still
a great deal we don't know our babies as
we expand think I remember and recover
more pathdata perhaps we'll find our
answers
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that was an introduction of dead
man played by guillermo del toro also
introduction of bill by the saga we need
a baby photo military theory to Moscow
Korea they take oh no Thomas
now you saw the video explaining what
Bibi was about and you saw that Sam
always had this baby in his pod and I'm
wondering what it was about so that
gives a great explanation of it I'm
gonna be veto some Gazzaniga reported a
big invaded Korea
Cochino ii try to correlate this way so
it's again another kind of a sad story
that Sam has with the baby because the
BB is connected to the world of the dead
and that allows the connection between
BB and Sam so that the Sam could see the
BTS the Minamoto not baby Tony veto
someone who can't get anymore story not
you much that was so you so you will
kind of have this journey with the baby
together and you will have attachment
and and more connection and that will be
the part of the gameplay Wow well it's
pretty amazing to see the level that
you're thinking of the two worlds
everything coming together it's it's
amazing
well mr. kijima I think everyone here is
excited to see characters but I don't
know about you but we want to see some
gameplay of des cranek
[Applause]
right understand automata Master I'm
kind of thinking of showing the gameplay
at Tokyo Game Show
Jeff since it's it's just show and
everyone's so excited I would like to
show you just a little bit of it here we
kind of a hint to you as well Vickey
starter told us and of course there'll
be a little gameplay that I would like
to show you next but there'll be a kind
of a star that will come out make sure
you catch that star that appears let's
look at it together all right here we go
the first gameplay death stranding
[Applause]
just a little longer
let's get it over
[Applause]
nothing
over here I'm Sam hey
anyone anybody hear me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
delivering cargo
[Music]
be a mail after problem Hey
hoping maybe you can
Thank You Carly
weapons restrictions lifted
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the voice is different by we are asked
Jeff to appear in our game as a cameo
thank you it was honored to be asked to
be in the game Matthew Mercer actually
does the voice of the characters that I
play in the game and I know there are a
bunch of cameos in the game as well from
from friends of yours tell me a bit
about the gameplay that we got to see
there what do I know it's a new style of
game and you've talked about you know
the Strand John and I think it's very
important to be able to see there are a
lot of hints there about the type of
game out there mr. stone I dismiss I
can't really say so much but you're
you're gonna play a Sam and you're gonna
have to connect the fractured cities and
people from east to west and you have to
connect and there are some obstacles in
the way like BTS or terrorists and there
are along the way you'll find people
like living alone like you saw Jeff we
call it Preppers main story honking nice
to us there are actually kind of hiding
so some Preppers don't really have to do
with the main storyline so you might
want to find these Preppers along the
way and if you kind of get connected
with them you might have some good
things that they provide you
they say ko tsunami a kundus Kamal
so no genie second ominous anger it's
not a pill to you
so Scooby don't give so I can't really
reveal too much but when you start to
like this in the game with Preppers and
others you will notice that you're kind
of connected to the people worldwide
they can toggle it to the video they
massacred Oh be nice to reaso cattle at
all not good no day so good I asked o
Keaney video a prestige [ __ ] No so in
the video with mr. del Toro
he explained about the baby sometimes
get the self poisoned you saw in the
gameplay as well when you kind of fell
the baby is stressed so what you do is
you used playstation force motion
controller sensitive controller and you
kind of like but if you fast the baby
will get angry so make sure you kind of
handle with care' my stuck at all about
the urine fire it's late enough to kind
of it discuss about that right my Camaro
mas demo some uses so if you're like try
to be try to move the camera and try to
see what he's doing Sam will move away
so you'll never see actually what he's
doing but and also there's an option
where you cannot release yourself like
that like if people are new years so
don't worry Norman fans you won't have
to be you know you don't have to worry
about that although I heard is it true
that that also can be a weapon though in
the game Boogedy one that he must she be
a good king so yes it could be used as a
weapon but also it could kind of it
would be kind of one of the key and
you'll find out later
Mina Sako coquito
you saw the mushroom growing so if
everyone kind of does it at the same
spot a whoa
we'll have something good later on well
of course that's not the main part of
the game okay
the main part is to connect the world
together Wow well I gotta say it's so
amazing to you know get a little insight
into your mind between those clips and
the gameplay like everyone's trying to
piece together how this all fits
together but it's amazing stuff now I
know we have some photos when I got this
it was a couple years ago when you
scanned behind you wouldn't even tell me
what we were doing but you're like come
down to San Diego it said here they put
dots on my face they did the full scan I
was there the same day that Nicholas
wasn't Reverend did his scan as well
it's almost like I think September
October two years ago and I know what
you're gonna do it that you're like
trust me Jeff I'm like okay sure and
then I find out I'm Luden's fan right so
if you find him in the game and if you
go to him and make the connection with
him he might give you something good
because what it didn't they
Jeff is actually a parent and you could
find him easily so when the game comes
out just look for Jeff okay well I'm
honored to have a little role with a
cameo there'll be some other cameos I'm
sure as well in this game so this now no
mother at all yes I can't really say who
yet but there are many people in cameos
mr. kijima thank you so much for coming
all this way to share a little bit more
a desk reading with us what do you guys
think
there's so much there and we don't have
to wait long if you guys are on track
for the game to come out this November
right that's it alright mr. keema thank
you so much yes that's right and mr.
Kojima will also be doing a signing
session here at Gamescom right and
that'll be one more thing sorry Rika
company becau Rihanna breathing no more
boost there at the Sony booth you'll see
more about like the briefing the reason
why Sam has to do this the briefing
scenes you'll see at the Sony booth from
tomorrow so if you have time just stop
by you understand what you saw today
with trying to find Jeff and things like
that so it will be you you'll get to be
revealed more you'll be understanding
what we saw today awesome alright so
there's a briefing scene at the Sony
booth mr. Kojima will also be doing a
signing and I can't tell you how much we
all appreciate you coming all the way
from Tokyo just as you're finishing the
game to be here for me to be here for
the fans give it up mr. Kojima thank you
so much my friend it's always such a
pleasure
Aki thank you so much down Kojima
alright guys well that's gonna do it for
our first ever games come opening night
live you got